so listen first of all uh uh Jen I got
to start with you
um you started playing a video game at
home you became a professional race car
driver uh now there's a movie made about
you
um how have you played the lottery yet I
mean like to like a scratch card because
you'll probably win like 10 million
dollars now I've played the lottery once
earlier this year and uh yeah like uh
something happened to me and I was like
okay
the person said look you should play the
lottery tonight euromillions and I lost
but uh no I've been very fortunate in my
life I've been in the right place at the
right time very fortunate to have people
around me tell me you need to know what
you want to do in life
um that'd be my father
um
and when the opportunity came to be I
was all in and
off the back of that this has happened
Archie playing me it's wild like if you
write it out it's very very far-fetched
kind of story
um
but yeah it's my it's been my life so
far the crazy thing is if someone
actually wrote this screenplay they
would no one would make it because it's
too unbelievable that's so true that's
so true Arch I gotta ask you a question
so I know that you practiced heavily uh
playing video games playing the game to
get ready for the role what was it like
telling your friends and family listen
I'm gonna be busy the next week I need
to play video games everyone I mean
everyone was number one very jealous uh
and number two everyone wanted to join
them and come and help me prepare for
work
um but I was to say like you know I
wasn't a gamer growing up and so it was
because I always had I've got quite an
obsessive personality so I just knew I
had that thing where you play for hours
and hours and hours then you think what
have I done with my entire day and it
was this unbelievable opportunity to
like look past the shame of wasting of
wasting the day and being like I'm at
work I'm doing something productive this
is so great I could tap into what Yan
was feeling being like this is actually
leading to something this is great it's
not just me playing The Sims for six
hours like it's this is like I'm doing
something I'm doing something
constructive so I mean it was a dream
come true loved it I'm curious what what
did what surprised you about the way a
Hollywood movie is made because
obviously this is your first time I know
you were the Stunt Driver on the movie
and you must have learned so much about
making a movie so what surprised me was
the attention to the attention to detail
and the scale of that as well the amount
of personnel on set so I turned up at
the Hungarian ring which is a track I
raced at seven years ago for a single
seat erase
and of course the racetrack was full
full of teams full of trucks and
personnel and cars and people
um but when I turned up on sale on the
first day it was as busy as it was seven
years ago but we happened to be there I
was there for the movie which shot which
really I had a conversation myself I was
like this is really weird you got to be
prepared for this because it's going to
be very mind-bending
and everybody has a job for everything
the for example the the cars the
attention detail when they were shooting
the Le Mans scenes uh you know when
hours go by office of course in real
life the car gets debris on the car and
same in the movie there was a person
kind of making sure that the car has
more debris and more rubber and marks on
the car than as the movies progressing
through the through the Lamar scene so I
was like what it's just very minor
things it's just staggering to me and
how it's all put together as well I I
don't have the capacity in my small
brain to
when they shoot something to think okay
that's how they're shooting it for that
to happen on screen
I find that part the Artistry really
interesting so I was always watching the
actors and how they prepare for each of
their role as well so I was like
watching you some people were very
different in the way that they prepare
themselves before jumping into uh a
scene so I loved it it was fascinating
to me you're not short uh and I'm
curious what it was like uh with racing
scenes because you're a big dude you
know what I mean and generally race car
drivers are not as tall as you you were
right
um they were painful uh it was truly
painful yeah we had to take the like the
padding out of all of the seats so that
I was just sitting on like the bare
bones of the shell
um like and the thing is we would I
would always have the widest the the
widest the most deficit and it's still
you know it was still a tight squeeze in
there my head is touching the roof my
you know I'm I'm constructed it's
unbelievably claustrophobic it adds to
that feeling of claustrophobia and
anxiety and and doing this but there is
something that actually when I look past
how miserable I was when I was doing the
actual scenes it helped it helped it
helped get into character because you
there is nothing you there's nothing
else you can think about but you you are
so focused on on you and your thoughts
and when the camera is so close to your
face the albeit you know you could mean
sometimes in his helmet only really see
my eyes that's all that you've got to
play with like and you've got so many of
these thoughts like kind of losing
around your head and and it kind of
allows for all of that all of that
expression to to be conveyed but
I I mean it was truly one of the hardest
things I've ever done being in that car
I just I have so much respect for for
all race car drivers it is
painful it is taxing physically it I I
would be ringing out my clothes with
sweat by the end of it I'd be throwing
up getting out of the cars being in the
cars I mean it was one of the most
physically
physically testing things I've ever done
and thank God I love the film and it was
not in vain because if I had if I'd
walked away and I hated the film I would
have been I don't know what I would have
done but Neil flew into to watch the
film with me and I turned to him and
just said thank god dude thank God it's
good it's so good it's so good one of
the things my last thing for you because
I'm just about out of time uh he used uh
Neil used new cameras that he could put
them in places that you know with the
because of the I believe it's the Sony
Venice too or I forget the name of the
camera
um so what was that like actually
working with new technology like that
and then actually for both of you seeing
the finished film and seeing the cool
shots that he was getting incredible it
was um yeah a fast for many of us pretty
much all of us on set I mean we would we
would shoot sometimes with up to 10 10
11 cameras at a time it was like it was
so unbelievable the amount the amount of
footage we were able to take and David
just told the story earlier of
of the the US shooting super wide and
David asking Neil um are you going to
come in anytime soon he's like oh I am
in dude I'm in and he was shooting on
this unbelievably long lens and
unbelievably close but wanted to keep
the feeling of distance and these
cameras just were so perfect for
capturing that so sometimes I mean they
were like football fields away and able
to capture like unbelievably close
unbelievably close a microscopic detail
it was it was stunning
um and and so it just meant we just knew
Jacob deep we just knew we were in the
best hands possible and it just what it
really gave it gave us the opportunity
to play so much because cameras could
keep their distance cameras you know can
and and you feel totally immersed in the
scene and we've also knew that we were
capturing so much footage at once like
that is kind of unbelievable you're
being covered from all angles doesn't
matter where you turn there's a lens on
you somewhere and that is it means that
you're not not just going over and over
again the same tiny scenes you've caught
three six of it in just one in just one
take and that was amazing that was
really cool well it looked uh that the
scenes in the movie uh there's we use a
lot of drones it looks like a it looks
like a Gran Turismo game intro so it
looks very Dynamic and but it's not it's
real life these Camera scenes these
scenes haven't been been used before in
a recent movie nothing is static and um
yeah I'm very happy it's it's shot
beautifully and Neil all the guys they
did an amazing amazing job and I love
personally I love the scenes like in the
in the pits with the rain it just looks
looks intense it looks real it looks how
it is it's there's a lot going on the
detail
yeah I'm very very happy on that and I
need to stop I'm going to say a sincere
congratulations and I really hope the
movie's a huge hit for you guys thank
you so much thank you nice to see you
man